[Music]
good afternoon everyone welcome to the
press conference for following our
European special European Council Summit
uh we'll start with the president of the
European Council sh Melle
president good afternoon to all of you
we've got an agreement an agreement on
the multi-annual financial framework
this is an agreement which shows the
leadership of the European Council and
of the European Union in December we'd
already made significant progress to
give candidate status to Ukraine and to
mova and to start negotiations with
Ukraine and mova and today we're going a
step further we got the 27 heads of
state and government to uh reach
political agreement which will allow us
to mobilize 50 extra billion euros as
part of the Ukraine facility I think
that this decision sends out a very
clear message to the ukrainians and
shows our
determination to be fully mobilized to
support their future to support their
freedom and it's also a message to our
our European populations it shows our
unity and European leadership and it
shows that we are not intimidated by
Russia which is infringing Europe
international law and it's a message to
the United States to our partners in the
world uh that we support Ukraine and its
territorial
Integrity this uh Financial agreement
will also allow us in the future to
spend money on other subjects the
Western Balkans for example migration
the external dition uh the external
dimension of migration on technology and
on defense now on Ukraine that's an
absolute priority for us and will remain
so so a military support for Ukraine we
had the occasion today to discuss in
depth how this important to make more
effort for more ammunition for more
military equipment for Ukraine we have
made good progress in supporting Ukraine
through the European peace facility we
have decided to task our ministers to
finalize work we understand how this
important to deliver and this debate
today was extremely useful to make very
clear that we are determined to make
more efforts and to make sure uh that
Ukraine will get the military equipment
they they need uh to defend their
country and to defend their future we
also had the occasion to welcome the
political agreement on using windfall
profits on Russian frozen assets to help
rebuild Ukraine and the idea is to
continue to work on this track which is
also an important one and once again we
have discussed how we need to address
the question of the circumvention of
sanctions we are still determin to make
sure that everything is done to reduce
the possibilities to avoid those
sanctions which Target Russia and the
Kremlin this is the first element I
wanted to mention for um this European
council meeting the second topic I would
like to uh mention and to explain what
you have discussed is the situation in
the Middle East and you know that we do
not have weitten conclusions on the
Middle East but yet once again an
indepth exchange of views on the
situation in that
region and let me try to um give you a
summary of uh what we agreed on that
subject the first point is that we are
extremely determined to continue in
Europe and with the support of Our
member states to reduce as much as
possible the risks of regional ex
escalation in particular in the Red Sea
we know how important that is and the
second point is that we of course are
determined to continue to
um do what we can to um plead for the
freeing of the hostages with no
conditions attached and we will continue
in partnership with uh member states and
also our International Partners to do we
can to make sure that humanitarian a Aid
is delivered to Gaza we know that there
is a major pressing need on that subject
every civilian life counts every life
counts and that's why we need to be
mobilized there and the third point I
wanted to mention because here too there
was uh strong political agreement within
the European Council and that is how
important it is to rela relaunch the
negotiation process for a two-state
solution and we want once
again called out called that that's
called out for a two State solution a
guarantee of the existence of the two
peoples that they can coexist in peace
in the future and uh so we need there to
be peace not just between Israel and the
Palestinians but between Israel and all
of its neighboring countries as well we
discussed what the uh elements were led
by high representative Bell
and uh we have the idea of initiating a
peace conference with other actors and
we will be coming back to that at a
future European Council to that subject
and our ministers will continue to be
very uh engaged in such an important
subject and a final word we're meeting
at a time where in a number of European
countries including in Belgium and uh
you will have seen that around this
building that our farmers are expressing
their anger their discontent and their
concerns about the future and uh it's
important for us to address that subject
as well and we have reaffirmed not just
how important the common agricultural
policy is for us it's one of the core
pillars of European policy and uh
there's an essential role for the common
agricultural policy and after that the
commission told us about the first
short-term measures that have been taken
and also a process that has been
launched to bring together points uh
some of the major points that came out
of our meeting which showed once again
that the European Council can surprise
people surprise people by our unity and
our capacity to uh discuss and reach uh
Speedy solutions to difficult questions
and difficult problems uh and so I'd
like to thank all of the teams who've
worked so hard uh since December in fact
since the uh the day after the last
Summit where we decided to um come back
today to uh reach uh answers to
questions such as Ukraine thank you
president from the line you have the
floor thank you so much today is indeed
a very special day the European Council
reconfirmed Europe's unwavering
commitment to stand with Ukraine we all
know that Ukraine is fighting for us so
we will support them with the necessary
funding and provide them with a much
needed predictability they deserve and I
think these 50 billion EUR for four
years also sent a very strong message to
Putin just ahead of the second
anniversary of his brutal
Invasion but today we also agreed on the
first ever revision of our multiannual
budg budget it confirms the priorities
that the commission has presented back
in June and I'm very very satisfied that
we got 80% of the funding we asked
for we had certainly some difficult
choices to make but we have a very good
result we reaffirmed our commitment to
fight illegal migration we reaffirmed
our commitment to support our Western
Balan Partners this is the part of the
growth plan that is in that budget and
the southern neighborhood we will also
increase our ability to deal with
natural disaster ERS in member states
and humanitarian crisis such as Gaza and
furthermore step will support the much
needed development of critical
Technologies in Europe including on
defense and increase our
competitiveness so with this agreement
Europe stands United and is well
equipped for the challenges ahead in
other words today Europe got
stronger we will also continue to
support the brave Ukrainian Armed Forces
to fight off the brutal
Invaders our military assistant to
Ukraine has been an has meet an met an
unprecedented level of effort so far the
European Union and its member states
have mobilized 28 billion EUR worth of
military equipment and of course more is
coming and of course more is needed more
tanks helicopters air defense systems
missiles and and of course more
ammunition the European industry defense
industry has already increased its
production capacity by 40% and this is
still growing over 80 European
manufacturers have responded to our call
for
proposals so we will be signing the
contracts in a matter of weeks and we're
working with the member states to get
that um ammunition to Ukraine be it from
the national stocks orbe it by diverting
other orders or making new orders as
I've just
described we will have delivered 520,000
rounds of artillery shell by March and
we will more than double this amount uh
by the this amount by the end of this
year on top of that we have been
training Ukrainian soldiers 40,500 so
far
mid-February but this support must
increase and that was the discussion
today in fact Russia's Invasion has also
been a wakeup call for the whole of the
European Union so while we keep
supporting Ukraine we need to bolster
our own military capacities too we're
working to take our defense industry to
the next level and this is why the
commission will soon present a new
defense industrial strategy it will
introduce a stronger European Dimension
across our defense industry hisory and
this goes from planning to procurement
will have a greater coherence and
coordination at the European Union's
level with this strategy we aim to make
Europe move from the emergency response
to a defense
Readiness let me add a few words on the
discussion on
agriculture Farmers play an essential
role in Europe's economy and society and
their work contributes greatly to our
food security and indeed also to our way
of life and they are key actors in
ensuring the sustainable use of Natural
Resources they live with nature and from
nature it is after all the basis of
their livelihoods and thus also the
basis of our
livelihood European farmers are
dynamic in 2022 productivity improved
13% thanks to their efforts
and they also contribute positively to
our external trade last year again Agri
food exports increased by
5% so I think it is fair to say that our
Farmers have shown remarkable resilience
in the face of the recent crisis but
many challenges remain for example the
tension on prices Agri food prices or
very competitive Global Market that
leads to un certainty and of course the
need to remain competitive while working
to high standards and Environmental
Protection a very complex
Endeavor the farmers can count on
European support the common agricultural
policy budget allocates close to €390
billion EUR that is almost onethird of
the European budget to
Agriculture and in 2023 alone Europe
provided exceptional assistance of over
500 million euros to Farmers most
affected by
crisis we know that this support is
crucial and we know that farmers are
making good use of
it but in parallel the commission is now
working closely with the member states
to address the immediate challenges this
week for example we have proposed
additional flexibility to Farmers on the
so called fellow land
use and we have proposed safeguards on
poultry eggs and sugar imports from
Ukraine to avoid a significant surge in
Imports finally of course we have to
defend legitimate interests of farmers
in our trade negotiations in particular
in ensuring a Level Playing Field in
terms of Standards when we have trade
agreements and I'm very very sensitive
to the message that farmers are
concerned by administrative burden this
is a general topic you know that this is
close to my heart to reduce these
administrative burdens so we will work
with the Belgian presidency on a
proposal that we then will present um
ready in time before the next
agricultural Council to work on reducing
these administrative burdens last but
certainly not least it's the long-term
mid and long-term proposal as you know
know we have started last week the
Strategic Dialogue on the future of
agriculture in the European Union in
other words we have convened all the
different stakeholders of course the
farmers Representatives the young
Farmers but also the food processors um
those who work in environmental NOS
Green Peace um other uh stakeholders in
the whole overall agricultural topic
the aim is that together we develop an
idea a vision and a road map how to
reach our common goals it was very
reassuring to hear that all stand behind
the common goal to reach climate
neutrality by 2050 but how to get there
this has to be developed with the
farmers with their knowledge because
they have many ideas that are very
interesting to move forward on this
topic so this was also uh a strategic
dialogue that we started uh last week
but of course it will bring the answers
in the mid and long term that will feed
in the program of the next commission
and certainly have an influence on the
next um negotiations on the
cap thank you President we will open now
the floor to questions we start with
Lawrence thanks thanks very much
Lawrence Norman at the W Street Journal
I have two questions one a slightly
technical one is the plan for the 50
billion in the short term to continue to
give Ukraine
1.5 billion a month and if the US
doesn't provide the assistance that it's
trying to get through Congress what
would it take to increase that amount
and secondly a political question at a
time when there are multiple Global
crises
and Europe faces all kinds of
challenge do you and the other EU
leaders share what Donald Tusk called
this morning Oran
fatigue you want me to start please okay
so um indeed the 50 billion package is
not evenly um distributed over four
years but we have the flexibility with
within this
package um to distribute the money as it
is needed and best
allocated no decision has been taken in
detail so far but it's not a rigid
delivery but a in itself a flexible
budget
um well and the second question I think
I leave to
you I I understand better why you wanted
to ask first to to reply
first no thank you thank you and uh and
I would like to to tell you that I'm
absolutely convinced that the the role
of the European Council is to to try to
be the guardian of the European unity
and it's challenging it's not always
easy sometimes it requires a lot of
effort but look in December uh we took
Everyone by surprise because uh we were
able uh in December to make fun
fundamental decisions in order to open
negotiations with Ukraine and with mova
and we had an agreement with 26
countries on 2 7 on the what we call the
neob Box the the the the proposal of
budgetary review and I'm extremely
pleased that once again we succeeded to
guarantee the unity of the European
Union and to make sure that 27 countries
uh made an agreement on the review of
the multiannual framework including this
very strong political signal that we
sent to to Ukraine with this package of
50 billion euros and for what
asked about the United States I repeat
once again that I'm abolutely convinced
that this decision is also a signal to
the American taxpayers this the
demonstration that within the EU we
assume we take our responsibility and we
know that uh we must show our leadership
and we must show that we are reliable
that we are credible and I hope that it
will be also help those in the United
States uh to to be um to to those who
are determined uh to to to get concrete
results in terms of additional financial
support for Ukraine and not only in the
United States because we have many
like-minded partners across the
world
R thank you uh my name is Razia akot uh
work for aan France press AFP news
agency I wanted to ask because of some
of the comments that Orban had made did
uh Mr Orbin receive any assurances or
guarantees that funds would be unlocked
did he get anything and this is a
question for both of
you let me be absolutely clear we had a
debate on the
mff we had a debate to confirm the
agreement of the 26 on the whole package
with the funds for Ukraine the 50
billion and money for the Western
Balkans migration solidarity and uh
natural
disasters those are just a few of the
subjects that we discussed that's the
first point and if you look at the
conclusions you will see that we also
refer back to the conclusions from
20120 in those conclusions we said that
the commission had a
responsibility uh to implement uh the or
to allocate funds so basically this is
reference back to what we agreed in
December 2020 and we are assured that
the commission will carry out the
necessary assessments on the basis of
progress made it was an important
meeting in terms of of confidence and
when you managed to get an agreement
amongst 27 heads of state I think that
goes to show that there is uh enough
trust around the table to move forwards
in the same direction even though at the
outset there was different points of
view we saw that in December
uh in December we had support from 26
but we still had to bring the 27th
member State on board uh for the
agreement on the mff including funds for
Ukraine and you'll also see that we have
uh ensured that there will be an annual
debate on funding of the Ukraine
facility and there the commission will
be invited to make proposals where
necessary is very simple there is a law
there's a law on cohesion funds there is
a law on Next Generation EU and there's
the law on the con um um conditionality
mechanism and these laws have nothing to
do with the Ukraine facility and the
midterm review this was reassured today
um and therefore the answer to your
question is a simple
no thank you president um Robert
thank you very much Robert litu Romanian
media two questions one for president
the first one for president Michelle uh
while thanking and feeling grateful for
the support that he has gained from the
European Union President zalinski also
fears that if the United States will not
be able to support further then maybe
Europe will follow the same tra uh after
this deal
today uh do you think that the European
Union can and will be able to support
Ukraine whether and if the United States
will not be able to do it in the near
term or after the November elections and
for president ferion a question on
migration and and shenen one of the
ideas that came through after this
reshuffle of the budget we have two
extra billion euros for uh migration and
Border management uh request
from the Austrian government do you feel
that it's a good step and enough in
order to ensure the
full um joining of Romania and Bulgaria
uh in shenen with also the land borders
thank
you I would like to to affirm that we
are absolutely determined to support
Ukraine and the decision that we met
today uh is was it's one additional
proof of that we are extremely Det
to support Ukraine because we understand
very well what's at stake and I repeat
again that we know know that the ukra
are fighting for their own future they
are fighting for the children they are
fighting for the Democratic principles
they are also fighting for our
Democratic principle they are fighting
for the rule of law for the
international law for the charter for
all those principles we we we strongly
believe in and is the DNA of this
European Union's project this why there
is a strong support for Ukraine not only
with money this was an important
decision made today but also with
military equipment and with political
support and this is the enlargement
process which is a clear signal that you
are not intimidated intimidated by uh
the Russian behavior and by the kremin
behavior I cannot talk on behalf of the
United States but I'm confident that
this that this decision that you have
made today will help in the United
States those who are determined to
support Ukraine for as long as it
takes as you know uh um the commission
is since uh years convinced that Romania
and Bulgaria are ready for
shenen um and it was very helpful that
in the last months we have had several
projects funded by the European Union um
to strengthen the Border in Romania and
Bulgaria also the processes at the
border and that we had fact finding
missions that were convincing for the
first steps now uh that were done by uh
Austria um concerning shenen air and uh
sea and I'm deeply convinced and you can
count on us that we will continue uh
with strengthening the border and
convincing Austria that this is a
full-fledged achievement by Romania and
Bulgaria that deserves uh the being in
shenen fully and indeed I think we have
proven today by these 50 billion euros
uh that we stand by Ukraine um and I
think it will be an encouragement for
the United States States also to do to
do their fair
share take the last question
David thank you thank you David K radi
radical Italian radio um a question on
on Ukraine but on on the other issue the
debate on uh uh deliveries of weapons
and so on ammunition uh today president
zeleski in in speech HED for uh 20
billion uh 5 billion per year for four
years in the conclusion of the European
Council uh there is no figures in the
draft there was one figures of five
billions um are you ready to go full in
support of Ukraine we have seen more and
more uh uh critical messages from from
Kev for example uh on the fact that
Europe is not doing uh what is saying uh
it want to
do um and the second question on on um
on Ukraine to the president of the
commission uh when you say
prioritizing ammunition
contracts what do you mean are you ready
to do what you have done with vaccines
for example so
blocking uh deliveries to Third Country
because Ukraine is the priority
or
not perhaps just one question in French
as well we know that the farmers are
outside now in revising the budget
you're cutting 1.2 billion from the
common agricultural policy and from the
cohesion
policy isn't there a contradiction there
when you
say we want um a capap which uh is
closer to the farmers and then you take
the decision to cut the European budget
and not just that there's Horizon and
other things you're cutting as well so
isn't that a bit of a negative
message let me start on that on the last
the second question it's not fair to say
we're cutting it's the opposite really
we're putting more money in perhaps not
as many as the European commission
wanted but nevertheless if you compare
it to the current mff we are increasing
the money there it's important to say
that because lots of people are saying
I've read a lot that we're cutting and
it's not the case we're increasing quite
significantly the money available not as
much as the commission wanted the
commission were even more ambitious uh
than the mff but that nevertheless the
money money is going up now uh you said
1.2 1.5 uh billion EUR in the cohesion
fund and that's not money that's going
for um direct support to member states
it's administrative uh money linked to
uh managing the cohesion funds and so
that's just a little technical Point
relating to your second question now on
the first question it's essential
fundamental and I can tell you that in
preparation of this meeting and during
the meeting we felt how the leaders they
are aware they are conscious that this
is fundamental to deliver and to deliver
on our promises you remember that a few
months ago we made the promise we
committed to deliver 1 million
Ammunition by the end of the year we
need to speed up we need to accelerate
and we need to identify what are the
Wiss for us to be too slow in our
deliveries and you in your question you
mentioned an important topic and I had
the occasion in the meeting to draw the
attention of the colle on the topic this
is the question of the exports to third
countries and here based on my
understanding this is a responsibility
at the national level uh to allow uh the
companies to export to third countries
this one possible tool one possible
leverage this a national resp ibility
point one but there are some other
elements we need also to see with the
companies with the defense companies if
we can um adapt some orders if we can
try also to identify how we can speed up
uh the production you know to be able to
deliver uh more quickly to the Ukraine
but we had a good decision on that we
were very operational and I can tell you
this is also a debate we had in close
coordination with the high
representative uh who is play a very
important control to try to coordinate
the MS of Defense so that there is a
clear Clarity among the member State who
is doing what and what can we do to be
more more effective in that field and
finally you set five billions on a
yearly basis or 20 billion on mul anual
basis for the European peace facility
they start in the text yes in fact this
is se but this in the text because we
refer in the text of conclusions to the
the the the the the proposal uh on the
table and the proposal on the table this
five billion on a yearly basis and 20 in
total but what's what's the the the the
the most important thing the member
states and this is very legitimate they
would like to work in parallel on the
numbers and on the modalities and
probably the direction we should take in
my opinion uh for the European peace
facility is the following we should
shift from a reimbursement mechanism and
we when we started it was a more
reimbursement approach that we have put
in place for obvious reasons to be very
quick and to be very efficient towards
an approach an approach more based on
common procurement on on on and support
for the European uh defense industry
it's exactly what we are discussing with
the member State there's a proposal put
on the table by the by the high
representative and by the commission and
it was very interesting to observe that
the member states would like to be
actively part of those debates by making
suggestions to improve uh this this
reform this decision making process and
at the end we have a a strong tool in
addition with the bilateral efforts that
are made by the member states to support
Ukraine with more military
equipment yeah I think almost everything
has been said uh so just wanted to
remind that is this famous three track
approach that has been weeks ago uh
proposed by the commission and agreed by
the European Council So within this
Frame all these activities take
place
thank you for
attending
in supporting ukra through the European
peace facility we have decided to T
clear that we are determined to make
more efforts and to losing windfall
profits on Russian frozen assets to help
rebuild Ukraine and the idea is to cont
trct which is also an important one and
once again we have discussed how we need
to address the question of the
conclusions on the Middle East but yet
once again an indepth exchange of views
on the situation in that
whe
member states and humanitarian crisis
such as Gaza and first furthermore step
will support the much more is needed
more tanks helicopters air defense
systems missiles and of course more
ammunition too we're working to take
our
[Music]
fore I'm going to
for